all right guys no guess what we are
reviewing today based on the title and
of course what's on the table we got an
exclusive here the geek culture studios
of
marvel studios avengers endgame iron man
nano gauntlet from hasbro here it is
let's check it out
[Music]
like all our reviews we're not paid or
sponsored unless we tell you but big
thanks to hasbro singapore for sending
this over our way i think we are the
first in the world to actually test this
out
if that's the case
we're very honored thank you hasbro for
that okay so as you can tell we've got a
number of gauntlets here we've got
thanos's we've got a uh
the hulk gauntlet or we think it's a
whole gauntlet because it looks slightly
different from other variations out
there but this is the official
gauntlet that i guess hasbro sold as
well they didn't say it's a hulk one but
it looks like that way because i don't
remember tony stark's hand that big
and
we've got a gauntlet from our good
friends over from china
and then we have
the official hasbro gauntlet here so i'm
gonna open this up we're gonna walk it
through it it says it can snap it says
it can do some other things we'll try
out all the features i'll compare it
amongst these three we've got a special
one that i think we're gonna be bringing
it from downstairs that lights up right
now
yes we got it and
we're gonna end the video with the
largest gauntlet you might have ever
seen i would say it's a very special
piece of the geek culture studios
downstairs because we cannot fit it here
you'll find out why at the end of this
video so stay uh look out for that so
with that zacky let's open up the box
here
got that but before we open it up let's
take a look at the box on the outside of
it of course on every angle here's a
photo of the nano gauntlet
because
the nano gauntlets inside
i'm not the brightest wall in the
chandelier sometimes folks but you know
sometimes i do hit it out of the park
um
it does tell you some of the uh features
in various different languages i'm not
going to repeat them because
my uh
i'm not multilingual that way but it
does show that you can snap it does get
you it's for 14 and above so keep that
in mind parents because you know it's
got the you know the infinity zones on
that you don't want your kid to ingest
those and all of a sudden their stomach
lights up when you go to the hospital
it's not a good thing um three uh double
a batteries are required to power this
bad boy up
shows that the stones are removable it
does make a snapping sound how cool is
that
and uh 18 inches 45.8 centimeters so if
you've got massive large hands this
might not fit if you have two small
hands it might be too big we're gonna
find out if my hand which is not to say
decent size
actually fits the nano gauntlet
that's pretty much it man i mean it's
pretty uh you know
to the point the infinity saga let's
open up this back door
okay
first and foremost
we've got
the legends instruction manual ooh it
teaches you how to snap look at this if
you don't know how to snap it teaches
you how to snap there's a correct way to
snap this gauntlet we'll find that out
probably take me a few tries to get her
correctly uh
i see so it's like
i don't know we'll figure that out if
it's only that easy right if it's only
that easy but it usually is never that
case it shows you where you can put the
batteries in inside the gauntlet
okay
it's not rechargeable folks you can't
recharge your gauntlet
i don't know why but you know safety
first easy easier that way then do you
turn on the stones by pressing on the
uh soul stone here go away through all
this
magnets it's magnetic is it the soul
stone mine's going on mine
all right so you press on the mine stone
here and that'll actually turn it on and
of course then you have these have
magnets on each of the stones so you can
actually magnetic take it on and off and
yeah i think it's pretty uh to the point
in that regard okay
let's
now
remove
the gauntlet itself
how cool is this honestly we're a little
bit late to the game hasbro i mean this
movie's only been out for a couple years
i mean this could have come out you know
sooner rather than now but
no complaints i'm happy that it's out
first impressions looking at this
feels like it's
it's not that heavy
and it's not that light obviously this
is more of a collector's thing it's not
gonna be like a a hot toys very where
it's gonna be like solid metal or
something like that
or very hard heavy composite plastic it
feels like it's you know something that
you could play around with a little bit
let's uh you excited for the zacky yeah
yeah me too
just for me it's more color accuracy
screen accuracy i guess screen accuracy
is gonna be hard to do man it's gonna be
hard to do i mean red itself is
i don't know
yeah the red is a bit of a fire engine
red you know it's um but you know
iron man's suit red it's always changed
a little bit it's always changed through
the various different movies sometimes
it's brighter red sometimes it's got
more of a dark maroon kind of more urban
rustic red so this is on that fire
engine red look now looking at the first
uh just first impressions here obviously
the stones are inside they're gonna be
in the box somewhere um
is uh yeah you're not gonna see any of
those lines that light up throughout the
gauntlet remember at the end of end game
when you saw all the lights going
through the gauntlet you're not gonna
see that on this so like some cosmic
circuitry exactly cosmic circuitry i've
never heard of that before did they have
cosmic circuitry the way if you wait for
internals maybe they'll explain to what
cosmic surface circuitry is spoilers
spoiler alert it looks okay i mean this
is i wouldn't say i wouldn't put this to
let's say
a
hot toys uh level of detail i think for
you know for a fun collector that just
wants to you know pay a couple hundred
bucks for something
this is gonna be okay if you really want
something that's like screen accurate
you're gonna need to invest a lot more
money and that's not what this is for
it's more for fun a little bit of
cosplay halloween's around the corner
maybe you want to be iron man but you
need the whole suit you know what i mean
you just can't yeah it's a little bit
tricky that way anyway there that is
stones are in here
i mean that's pretty much in the box
it's not like it's um it's not nothing
like it's gonna win any awards for
packaging here i mean it's not like the
lightsabers out there that really you
know
are quite intricate in their packaging
okay here's our stones
mine stone
here we go
yeah i mean they're not shiny
they're matte in color
um
kind of lightweight
i mean
yeah it
as we say
it is what it is exactly
all right so
i guess we're gonna put batteries in
this bad boy we're gonna do that now and
then we'll come back and we'll put the
stones on we'll put it on my hand and
we'll see if we can
snap and bring back half of the world's
population this video is brought to you
by secret lab here at geek culture we
love our secret lab chairs especially
the all-new 2022 titan evo with its
revamped 4-way lumbar system for
enhanced back support the p leather 2.0
isn't your cup of tea then consider the
all-new soft weave even more soft and
breathable than before the chair comes
in more colors including this lovely
frost blue the titan evo is even
magnetized allowing the head pillow to
stick on the headrest without straps of
course there are even more new features
so do check them out at secretlab.com
so one thing to one of the things to
take note of on this gun lady when you
press on any of these empty spots
nothing's going to happen
right
but after reading the instruction manual
i'm hearing
it comes alive when you put each of the
stones in so here's the time so we're
gonna put here in the thumb area
oh
how cool is that
okay
now we are moving
to
the purple the power stone
now see it doesn't actually fit in there
because you got to fit in the correct
way so it's a little bit like a puzzle
then we got the space stone
[Music]
a little bit of that space sound right
then you've got the red stone
which is for reality
then
orange for soul stone
and then the soul stone
and now
to put in the final stone
the mine stone
[Music]
how cool is that
that is wicked
and now
the moment of truth
to put on the gauntlet to see if i can
actually put my hand in it first
then
snap
see this suit zacky i really need a suit
you guys have a suit here
no
after everything you got here at the
geek culture studios you don't have a
suit
so anyway let's put it on
and
it fits hey it fits like a glove
[Laughter]
zac is our comedian here okay now let's
see if i can
[Applause]
oh
do you see that check that out watch
this watch us
the sounds are cool
okay
interesting each of the stones gives a
different sound
now it's not as loud as i thought it
would be this could be a little bit
louder all right could be a little bit
louder
oh that's a
badass sound
yeah
okay
and the uh
there's no
repulsor here
it's just
silver
budget
just paint so if you think i'm gonna go
wow i can't do that actually my fingers
don't go up that much anyway okay so
before i go into this snap right because
a lot of people online have been asking
this question is it like a latex glove
and the answer to that is
predominantly no it's a hard plastic the
fingers do feel obviously there is some
sort of latex here but the fingertips
are hard on the outside it's just
underneath here where you bend is a
little bit like a
latex but it's like a thick rubber um
yeah even here with this uh the gold
thumb area here yeah the
this area is hard
soft
so everything else you do get some wrist
action like this but this is all hard
plastic so keep that in mind so it's not
the most
i mean
not going to be completely flexible what
you say is like you know if you want to
wash the dishes in style
no you're not washing anything with that
you're not washing anything at all
all right jackie moment of truth
ah
bobby i i i don't feel so good zack
zito
come on
see it's like a poo
is it a
gotta wait for it to flash okay
so we got a
very interesting snap effect here i wish
it was a bit louder because the snap is
supposed to be the big thing of the
gauntlet right but it's
we got to be honest about this they need
to get this better ah
oh this hurts man my knuckle
wow
look at my knuckles zacky look at this
you know this is not meant for
everybody's hand i don't think i think
you need a certain size hand but
and it's not consistent that's the sad
thing i wish it was consistent look
let me put it back on i'm going to put
my fingers all the way in
okay
i'll get it close to the mic so you can
see if you can hear it
so that's the sound
here's the thing
the snap is the biggest
you know thing of a gauntlet right you
want the world changes the universe
changes
but the sound is like
it sounds better than that but you know
what i mean it's so
bc
there needs to be a more impactful
sounds you know you're right
zach what do you think yeah compact it's
lackluster it's a little lackluster it's
a little lackluster you know i mean it's
kind of like
hasbro could have done so much more like
the whole all the lights just go crazy
and the sounds
it's duck sable all over again isn't it
you know you're kind of right
it's like they put the speaker somewhere
that you really can't hear it yes bro
are you listening to us come on
see i'm and it's not consistent here's
the thing
see
my knuckle his hurts
ow
there we go
yeah
ah
you know what we say to the zaki it
is what it is
well speaking of that right we uh since
we got the rest of the goblins around
let's show them some of the gauntlets
you're right zacky let's show you
some of our gauntlets our collection and
compare it to that great idea zacky
let's put it next to the hulk gauntlet
i thought the whole time would be a
little bit larger but
you
[Music]
all
know
yeah it's got coconuts
let's see it's like pretty much the same
sound profile right but it's just i
guess the the how big the speakers are
yeah i mean i guess you could say that
it's yeah obviously it's a smaller
gauntlet the speakers are smaller sound
profile is very similar in that regard
um
you know the uh whole gauntlet obviously
inside of it you've got uh uh
you know
areas where you can put your
your fingers inside and you can
articulate it this way
[Music]
yeah
yes it's a pulling mechanism inside
um it's more like a puppet
and then you can obviously put
you can yeah
lock everything down
push this button everything goes back up
the stones don't come out on this one
they stay in there
so it's pretty locked in
[Music]
wow
and each of the stones don't have a
sound like this one does so
i guess you could say
i mean this is a nice piece compared to
this one i think there's probably more
uh features in terms of the sounds with
on each of the different you know the
stones versus that but obviously you
have the pulley mechanism inside but you
don't need it for this because this is
obviously smaller and your hand can
actually fit all the way in
uh
i would say that there are slightly more
details on this one as well i like the
finger the articulation here it's all
sort of uh plastic and it feels a little
bit more it feels better in that regard
it makes those sounds see
this one is just basically
hard plastic on the outside and
just bounces right back into action
it's ready fraction
no
exactly
leave it leave it alone zacky leave it
alone i know where you're going with it
this is a family video
and then we also have thanos's gauntlet
somewhere
now this is also from uh
hasbro i love that sound man
you know the og just sounds really good
right it just gives you that
that thanos that
avengers infinity war and game sound now
of course when you press here none of
that
oh the sound profiles are fantastic on
the fingers
now these are the same concept in terms
of pulley uh
pulley um
yeah so these are the same concept in
terms of pulling mechanisms inside of
them okay um
all these are very you know plastic it's
much more sensitive i think than this
one is
really nice actually really nice but as
a matter of fact we've got a little
surprise for you that we'll show you at
the end of this video as well
and
we've also got another nano gauntlet
this one is from our good friends over
in china this one is 17 u.s
this one is interesting
because
it doesn't make any sounds
but you
you just
here we go all of these now obviously
when you you can
turn it on you can flash it
you can keep it solid and when you
remove it it stays lit up
now there is no sound to this at all
okay
um
and as a matter of fact
the mine stone was the orange one again
ah
but anyway the color of the glove looks
more accurate though yeah i would say
the color the glove is more accurate
this metallic red looks a lot better i
think than this one if we want to
compare the two
i would have liked to have seen the
hasbro version
actually have this metallic red but in
terms of size
these are radically different okay
obviously meant for adults this is meant
for kids this is completely latex there
is no hard plastic at all
except around the stone area to hold it
in and the stones themselves let me put
my hand in there yeah this is just like
a normal glove and you can
kind of snap
but nothing happens it's just
squishy
it's 17 guys what do you expect you know
what i mean but i will say the color is
quite nice on the red
okay
and now we're going to show you a very
special nano gauntlet it's not official
but
it's probably the most badass gauntlet
you can't wear it but you just put this
up and you're going to be like i want
that
yuck
bring down the bad boy now we've got a
very special nano gauntlet here this is
not an official gauntlet from hasbro or
anything else like that this is
a beautiful piece of art and it's on a
lazy susan so i'll turn it around so you
can actually see all the detail that's
there
uh i'll go around this one because it's
plugged in because it's plugged in for a
good reason
let's turn it on
[Applause]
yeah baby
wow
look at this
that's what i'm talking about you see
the lights the cracks and the lights
coming through everything this is like
what was in the movie
and you can see the repulsor even lights
up right here look at that
this is detail now of course you can't
wear this
but as a collector
this is
a grade
i need this in my home this is badass
it is amazing and it's heavy too this is
not light at all okay
um look at this
so in terms of price there is a
difference this is around 500 us this is
around 100 u.s so
when you look at the lighting and the
craftsmanship and the amount of detail
and just
the artwork that went into this versus
that obviously you're going to see the
difference
so this is going to be much more for
you know
teenagers
collectors that just want something fun
this is for the ultimate collector blank
yonk here who's our head geek at the
culture studios as we'll show you what
else we have downstairs and you'll
understand
why
we like our gauntlets
and avengers
but this is uh
pretty damn impressive
so
let me give you my final thoughts
downstairs with a very special surprise
and here we are
with a very special thanos from hot toys
this is a life-size version of thanos i
think we're the only one in southeast
asia actually has this this is in the
front of the geek culture office here
um
this gauntlet does not make any sounds
nor does it need to
this is
badass
so
here's my nano gauntlet
here's the real thing
final thoughts on this
it's a fun toy uh collectors out there
depending on how
intricate and how detailed you want your
gauntlet to be you may feel that you
want a little bit more out of this and i
might recommend the other one that we
had we'll put a link to where you can
pick that up in the description below uh
but for the fun people you know just the
casual collectors
you know
young uh teenagers or you know
men women
who just want something fun around the
house to uh you know
show off at a party anyway those are my
thoughts on hasbro's uh iron man nano
gauntlet let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below is this a pass
are you going to pick this up
love to hear from you follow us on
facebook subscribe to us on youtube like
this video helps out our channel a lot
with that stay safe take care i'll chat
in the next one right thanos
[Music]